stream set up
software
This never gets clipped.
Buy a new 5.
Yeah, I'm working on getting it stable
this weekend and today. I'm going to
basically just be streaming non-stop
until I get this done with a few breaks
here and there.
do short breaks here and there rather.
and figure out if this is the same.
J might have been more frozen.
main changes between four and five. Um
so five has asynchronous training, five
is pure CUDA, no Python. Um five has
some major improvements to various
different kernels.
And it looks like we're also going to be
dropping a few of the
old training settings that are no longer
required that we're adding complexity
and making hyper prams complicated.
I just
I'm just trying to track down a a
regression real quick. We have about a
1.5 second solve at the moment.
Yeah, I get myself like a bagel sandwich
and a soup.
my coffee as well.
I kind of just eat the same thing like
every day or almost every day.
I think I could genuinely just have soup
with every meal and I'd be happy with
that. Like literally just stick me a
good diner that always has like a good
chicken noodle soup or whatever and I'm
basically set.
Perfectly balanced meal.
Always good.
Do not make soup out of the puffer fish.
Um,
and it's also like
so I didn't I did not do like the
psychotically miserable
um cut like I did last summer,
but that was an extenduating
circumstance why I had to do that. Like
that literally took hospitalization
um to pause this
so this was last summer I was
okay I went from 185 down to 167.
So this summer I was a little bit leaner
to begin with and I went from like no I
was much leaner to begin with. So, I
went down from 180 I think 183 maybe
down to 171 and over more time.
I didn't Yeah.
So, it's not bad.
Actually, let me see. Was I leaner in
this photo or no?
Uh, I can't tell if I'm leaner now or in
this photo.
Yeah, I can't tell.
It's pretty close. I might be a little
bit leaner in that photo,
but it's pretty close. And I didn't make
myself completely miserable this summer.
Psychotic
is not exaggerated. No. Yeah, it's
completely psychotic.
That's a 1500 calorie a day cut while I
was running like I don't know 30 40
miles a week
Holy [ __ ] Yeah, every so often like
when stuff is tough, you know, when I'm
dealing with some I think I was working
on like the original Puffer 4 or
something back then as well. So
sometimes when I'm dealing with
something difficult instead of trying to
make other areas of my life easier to
compensate like sometimes I do that but
sometimes I just go completely the other
way and just say fine if stuff's going
to be difficult everything's going to be
difficult. You know,
this cut was not even like at all the
hardest thing I've uh I've done
fitness-wise.
The 50k was so much harder than the cut.
It's not even close.
Uh
huh. Huh?
How to start researching RL my guide on
X.
I have lots of educational material.
It's all free.
There's no sign up or [ __ ] You can
star the puffer on GitHub if you want to
help me out for free. So, lots of
research articles here.
And then these two guides are for
newcomers. my highest rated piece of
content.
What can I say, man? The puffer is fast.
I made some changes. All right.
as far as I know. He runs multiple
agents
on one machine.
50 mil for a normal run.
No, I can't get 100 mil, I don't think.
I mean, I could get a 100 mil SPS. Um,
but like if I did that, it would
basically be pure performative and it
wouldn't actually be useful. I could
stress test it to like 100 mil
throughput through the system.
Wait.
Huh?
What exactly is Puffflip? It's the
fastest reinforcement learning library.
I develop very fast RL infra training
models, architecture. We do our own
research. We build our own environments
and sims in a variety of different
areas. We do it all open source. We also
do stuff professionally.
Demos online on puffer.ai. They run in
your browser.
And I kind of stream most of the dev
because it entertains me and sometimes
it entertains you.
That is a side benefit though. It mostly
entertains me. Wait,
Oh. Okay. Okay, it's different for the
synchronous Yes.
solves arc.
It's not really RL.
It's the one real benchmark for It's not
It's massively overblown.
It's basically just a mostly pattern
matching thing that has a little bit of
interactivity.
Like there's so many actual real tests
for intelligence. They're out there, but
they make the language models look bad
so people don't use them.
Also, we do a different form of RL than
that. Um cuz the thing is those like you
literally can't learn any of those
problems from what's given in the
problem. You have to bring in external
pattern matching knowledge.
which is another thing that makes it a
very bad benchmark.
Yeah. Yeah. Because otherwise it was
still applying important sampling just
unclipped.
Okay.
ARC's definitely overrated. I mean, it's
a cool benchmark, but it's only
overrated because people have like
inflated it, right? It would have been
like a cool benchmark on its own, but
people kind of just like way over
claimed with it.
What was my main topic?
Uh, so it's actually pretty funny. Um,
if you're interested in my PhD work,
uh, it's a Are you on YouTube? You are
on YouTube. So, my thesis is on YouTube.
Fairly well watched as well. I put a lot
of work into this presentation.
Um,
it's probably the best presentation I've
given.
Uh we got a little bit of griefing on
the uh the recording, but it's not that
bad.
And I worked on neural MMO massively
multi-agent learning infrastructure
tools, approaches, and environment
design for like multi-agent learning
with lots of agents.
And I actually have my thesis here. So,
I'd really recommend that you just watch
the uh the defense rather than going
through my whole thesis,
the 170 pages of papers stapled
together. Essentially, though, you can
read like the abstract of the uh the
original thing, you know, the abstract
and the intro, I suppose, if you want to
learn more about this. And then um the
one other thing that's kind of cool, so
I didn't stop doing neural MMO after I
graduated. We actually have a successor
environment to my PhD environment that I
wrote by hand in C.
And uh it's a little janky on the
website. I need to put a a ship a
smaller model so it doesn't look laggy.
This is trying to run a neural net in
your browser that's too big.
But you actually can get all sorts of
interesting multi-agent interactions and
behavior directly out of this and then
combined with puffer to make it run
fast.
Two years ago. No, no, no, no. Not two
years ago, my guy. I've been working on
this since 2017, I believe.
Nine years.
Okay, now here we're cranking some
experiments.
Oh yeah, hasn't changed it one bit. If
anything, it's like
the fact that there's still such big
categories of problems where the models
are like the foundation models or
whatever are bad. First of all, it tells
you that they're not really foundation
models in the sense that you're not
building a strong foundation.
um they're just big language models or
whatever. Uh they've now poured hundreds
of billions of dollars into these things
and we still beat them with like 20,000
parameters a lot of the time or a few
hundred thousand parameters virtually
all of the time on these little
problems.
So I it really hasn't changed my view on
the stuff at all. If anything, it's like
I kind of roll my eyes and get annoyed
uh that like it's subsumed so much of
the field and I get really annoyed that
I can't really buy GPUs anymore because
the prices have tripled. But, you know,
yay, I guess I get to use some of the
models to uh speed up a little bit of my
own development work. So, that's nice.
Okay.
What are we doing? We are currently
cleaning up um puffer
five for release or for pre-release. I'm
doing a quick little sweep here just to
see if we find anything better on the
breakout sweep
cuz it's so quick. Like look, literally
every single one of these is a full
experiment like train from scratch every
two seconds. I'm trying to see if we
just have like a nice sub one second
solve in there. We have 60 mil SPS
training working quite nicely though.
That's nuts.
What the heck?
That's insane.
I'm gonna send this to Volo
like, hey, get our our our RL agent to
do this.
Very out there world model to generate
obs.
Huh?
World models don't give you pattern
matching Jess at all. That's the
opposite. World model gives you
dynamics. We learn dynamics trivially.
So no complete opposite of what you
need.
You need pattern matching in the sense
that you need to know what you're
supposed to do by looking at the pattern
and saying, "Oh, I need to make this
thing match this other thing." Right?
I'll let this run a couple hundred
experiments because it's super quick.
Um, it's occurring to me though that we
can literally just like increase the
time steps on the current one and it'll
probably work
All right.
Yeah. And it is the correct cost as
well.
Mixture of experts is not like actually
a mixture of experts.
Was cost being modeled as GP
linear or log linear?
Yeah, it was a deliberate choice, Rob,
because like that doesn't account for a
lot of stuff. Like first of all, there
are a lot of different variables that
can influence the speed.
And then second of all, ends themselves
often times the speed will change
depending on how good your agent is.
was reverting to the mean for uncertain
candidates.
Uh it should not be reverting to the
mean.
First of all, we don't even take into
account uncertainty of the GP in our
current model at all because I know that
the uncertainty estimate was not
reasonable for GPS.
Um
so second of all, it's not using a
linear kernel in the first place. It's
linear plus matern. So you do get
locality on that.
Interesting that we actually we get lots
of these stable solves
in the 40 mil range,
but with slower runs.
pretty standard in basian optimize. See,
I wouldn't know that. Ask Glitzy though.
Glitzy knows.
Batch batch size burst getting more
terminations.
Protein does it for you. eaten automatic
hyperparam sweeps. You don't guess
hyperparameters
unless you're trying to like match some
existing result which happens
occasionally. I had to do that yesterday
actually. Um you don't just guess
hypers, you sweep them.
Muan is an optimizer. Piss off.
It optimizes things.
Okay, we'll let it go a little bit
because that just found.77 second
849 solve.
We can always run this more later.
You're spoiled and that your Sim is
fast.
No, the sim is fast because I made it
You know, in our professional work,
typically people come to us with like a
big slow sim and then we make it fast.
well
and then sometimes we'll get people like
oh no no you don't understand it's
Python but it's fast because it uses
numpy
it uses the numpy
it's like all right listen to me even
though you have numpy you're still
running Python over numpy in a gigantic
loop.
No, because you're sweeping the model
size, you're sweeping the batch and mini
batch sizes, right? You're sweeping the
horizon.
You're sweeping the number of time
steps.
So yes, like obviously the total time
steps is going to have a nice linear
correlation,
but it is not at all the main or like
the only determiner of anything.
It's only the case that it's a linear
relationship for fixed other set of
hypers
functionable.
Yeah. But like the way that those
interact is a little bit
it's a bit fancy which is why we just do
it with the GP,
right?
It's funny to me. It's like so lame
seeing Breakout taking two seconds to
solve.
I mean, if you have um
if that's with a GPU end, it's not bad,
right? So, like one mil range if you're
using all the cores is not great because
that means that we can't even speed it
up on eight GPUs.
If it's a GPU sim that's in the hundreds
of thousands or low millions, that's
fine. If it's a CPU sim that only uses
like know four to eight cores and it's
in the low millions or high hundreds of
thousands, that's fine.
Max suggestion cost can be 100. Not I
literally have it set to three on this
J.
I have it's set to three.
GPU only. That's fine then. Oh, in that
case the thing I just did will speed it
up for you quite a bit. So, you were
asking how I got 60 mil SPS. Um, I could
have graphed the entire roll out, like
the whole end in the loop without
breaking.
Some other small changes as well, but
that was the big one.
Spin up a little test.
Yeah, we're done like waiting for sweeps
now. Now we get cleaning stuff.
Have you ever seen 63 mil SPS training
900 ms to solve breakout?
I mean, literally like look. Boom.
I think it's 026. Yeah. Yeah. It's still
deterministic. 900 ms.
Like I hear you about not wanting to
make the function super long, but make
the function super long. I don't care. I
do not like functions
that are only called once. I don't like
functions that have one caller.
Why does it exist? Why is it separate?
Wait, will 50 make RNG invariant to
execution topology
buffers or back? So, the back end is
just CUDA at this point. No more torch.
Uh, and if you'll see, this should not
concern you because look how simple it
is. 5K total lines of code for all of
our trainer.
Uh that's the model and everything. Um
buffers will change uh with buffers
will change trajectories.
I don't think you can make RNG invariant
like that man.
no, like fundamentally like coup blast
doesn't give you that strong of a
guarantee.
If you want everything to be identical,
you literally need to be doing like the
same additions in the same order.
So the Kublast guarantee just gives you
that on you can have different machines
um but and even different GPUs I believe
but as long as you have the same
parameters and the same CUDA version
you'll get the same result.
Now there is a seed parameter and for
stuff that is highly volatile you should
just run multiple seeds anyways which
you can do because puffer is very
8 mil so faster than warp. It really I
it's like it depends what you're
implementing, right?
how a beginner should get started.
Uh depends on what you mean by beginner,
but my articles,
these two articles, depending on uh
where you're starting. Hang on.
If you're newer to programming or even
just newer to ML and science stuff in
general, read this.
If you don't think that you're like a
whiz programmer already, probably read
this. A good litmus test here is if you
roughly understand the design of Puffer,
you probably don't need this. If you
don't, then you probably do. Um, and
then this is my guide to RL, which
I think I need to take a paper off of
this, don't I? Do I have Impala on here?
Oh, I didn't have uh Impala on here
anyways.
Did I?
Yeah. Yeah, I need to I need to I'm
going to make an updated version at some
point. It's pretty good. It's just like
I've sort of reassessed my opinion of a
few areas where I no longer think that
off policy stuff actually is worth
looking into because it just doesn't
work. Um, and there are a few other
areas as well.
The problem is if I keep updating it,
like every time I end up replacing one
of these papers with something else that
I've made, I get more and more into
Schmidt Huber territory where I'm only
linking my own work, you know?
link here, please. It's just my ex.
Like,
it's just x.com
like J Suarez.
Super simple link.
I'll drop it in here though. Anyways, do
I have reream open?
If I have reream open, I can drop it in.
Oh, we have a good number of people
watching. Hello everyone.
There, there's your link. Just my
articles tab on there.
Good time to point out this is all open
source. Throw the puffer on GitHub if
you're new around here. It's free.
It helps me out a lot.
Countbased RNG.
Um, honestly, like no, because
it really doesn't work. Um, like the
jack style RNG, first of all, makes a
massive mess of your codebase. Second of
all, often slows stuff down
tremendously. We've had several
instances where we've been dealing with
refactoring Jack's code or like porting
it, and the entire runtime of a thing
that's supposed to be fast is actually
just like completely redundant RNG.
Um,
and third of all, I still don't think
that that's going to even be enough
because like
it's RNG is not what makes your thing
non-deterministic most of the time. It's
nonassociivity of operations,
right? So even if you share the same RNG
across everything, that doesn't make
your code deterministic. Like if you
increase the size of a buffer or
something and now one of your reduction
operations is summing in a different
order, like congratulations. Your code's
no longer deterministic.
So, we actually already have pretty
decent RNG on stuff. That's not the
thing that'll make it non-deterministic.
Um, at least on its own. Like changing
that would not help, let's say.
Incredible how bad LM yeah convert. I
mean it's kind of fun. Honestly,
I like doing my end dev by And
Heck is this in softmax?
is softmax. Nice.
How do you think about reproducibility?
Is bitwise determinism. We do have
bitwise determinism.
Like we have bitwise determinism
as strong of a guarantee on it as you
can get from CUDA.
So like
it like assuming you're going to use
Kublast, right? Can we agree that you're
going to use Kublast for Matt moles?
Because as soon as you're using Kublas
for matmals, CUDA itself is not
deterministic
across different versions of CUDA,
right?
So if you run our same config in
everything on the same version of CUDA,
you get the same result.
That's as strong of a guarantee as you
can possibly get.
And that's typically the guarantee that
you want because it guarantees like if
you run an experiment,
right,
and you run it again, you'll get the
same exact result. So if you if you like
run an experiment and you change
something that you don't expect to
affect your numeric at all, but your
numeric change, you know that you messed
Puffer video G.
I mean, realistically, you probably
could make something domain specific for
Puffer that would be really good because
we have a pretty different uh set of
needs from most other stuff out there.
But like, yeah, that would be crazy
expensive for the stuff we're doing.
Like that's not even remotely practical.
I do hope in the future though that like
eventually there's so much money right
now on all the AI chips. Um, I do hope
eventually we just get a massive boost
in manufacturing
capability
and it becomes as a result of that it
becomes incredibly cheap to tape out uh
your own chips. That would be really,
really nice.
I don't know enough about hardware to
know if that's true.
20.
That's a little bit of code.
We have all sorts of axes of
parallelism.
We have some pretty fancy CUDA graphing.
Our architecture is co-designed for this
for hyperf.
I mean, if you take like any sort of
standardish
um RL loop and then you just like
naively port chunks of it to C++, you
won't get anything close to what we
Yeah, that's the 150 lines.
AI bubble. There's not an AI bubble.
There is There is an LLM bubble, though.
Rock 4.6 high. Soda. Soda. Blah blah
blah blah blah. Models are stupid.
Soda. Soda. Soda. Yeah, it's still
stupid.
Happens every single update. Oh, have
you seen a new model? It's so smart now.
So now we totally cannot think anymore
and just use language models for
everything. See? See, I was right. I
told you so. And then like one day
later, it's like, man, that's the
stupidest mistake I've ever seen.
I don't know how you can write a
thousand lines of code in 4 hours.
Convert would take longer than that.
Yeah, unfortunately this is
their thing doesn't work.
Copy chunks of Robo Code. Well, that
definitely took longer than four hours
to write.
I think I wrote the original like
300line version of Robo Code in about
four hours.
RL for chip design company.
I mean, that's one application. I don't
think it's the most valuable
application.
My biggest hope for Puff for a
scientific sim
stuff in bio, material science,
especially
I kind of see bio is the problem that we
uh need to solve if we want to be around
to solve anything else.
Recent comments not showing. Don't know
why. Sometimes
the chats just don't work.
Bin results.
PR on net hack.
the fin turn
harnesses.
I've used the like the one that is
shipped with the model. So, like it's
the native one.
Rock, flaad, um,
uh, soul. They're all dumb.
Every single time somebody comes to my
chat like, "Oh, but you didn't try this
version with this." And I go, "Try it
and it's still dumb."
Like, you can't write for loops around
something stupid and make it not stupid.
No, protein folding is one tiny part of
bio. You don't solve bio by solving
protein folding.
There's so many different things that
you can do in sim.
Hey Finn, thank you for Net Hack PR. Uh,
hang on. This is an overestimate. Let me
just show this off real quick.
How's 900 ms for a breakout solve?
yeah, I I made for preferences. I made
this thing which I mean this is really
dumb. It's just me writing down like
this is how I refactor stuff. It
actually does help in some sense. It
doesn't make it work but it reduces the
amount of frustration for sure.
I'm probably going to ship this without
any comment with Puffer live.
What? Inversely correlated. Isn't
biologyy's value almost inversely
correlated?
Um,
no.
I mean, it depends what you mean by
valuable.
I figure I make plenty of money doing
this stuff regardless.
I mean, in terms of like actually
solving problems we care about.
Coding has not been largely solved
earlier this year. These models are
[ __ ] horrible at it.
The people saying otherwise are simply
bad programmers.
Really that simple.
They can do lots of stuff.
They make a complete and utter mess.
Just kidding. It's hard to say. I mean,
it's hard to tell, man. People literally
come in my chat asking like, "Why should
I learn to think about anything anymore
if the LLMs can think better than I can?
And then I tell them, you know what?
You're right. You probably shouldn't
think about things. Go become a plumber.
You'll have a much more fulfilling life,
make more money, and nobody will have to
deal with your dumbass in uh in CS.
This is true, Kenvert.
I have much much more respect for your
average plumber than I have for your
average like Google software engineer.
What is this? another um
just like dystopian whatever.
lots of ripped.
I don't know what that even is.
All right, let's see. Uh,
I honestly don't even know what I'm
looking at here.
We'll clean this up.
Uniquely positioned that no one else is
working on.
Um, I think it's in general
it's allowing you to have simulation
that optimizes to an objective
rather than to
just specify the conditions and see what
happens. If you want the stupid techbro
version of it, it's like simulation++.
Um, the technical version of it is just
like RL with fast sim that actually
works.
general purpose interactive
optimization. I suppose
You could view it as a form of
intelligent search in Sim.
It's not quite though.
Um, I mean, if you think about it, like
there were a lot of completely worthless
devs long before there was any AI. And
in general, there are a lot of people
doing completely worthless jobs long
before AI. So like, yeah, you can
automate lots of things with AI, but you
can also automate lots of things by just
not doing them because they're not
adding any value anyways.
So I don't particularly care.
environment adapts in accordance to a
that's just non-stationary problems
works with non-stationerity quite well
I know from your thesis defense you do
have options
opinions what
I mean I always thought that like the
just scale up big sim and do RL in it
would be a viable path to general
intelligence that ship seems to have
mostly sailed at this point. Not
necessarily because it was wrong, but
just because the thing that people have
already made the massive monetary
investment in is language models and
there's a lot of inertia. Um, there's
some things that you'll get out of that
that you wouldn't have gotten out of my
version, but I think there are a lot of
things of from what I was saying that
you're not going to get out of language
models. though. I guess you can still
massively scale them in simulation for
RL, but like yeah, prepare for that to
cost trillions of dollars with how
inefficient their stuff is.
Um, meanwhile, we're still going to just
be here learning domain specific
solutions to a variety of problems for
pennies. So, do with that what you will.
World models are mostly um at least in
an RL context mostly a scam.
They're very cool outside of RL, but as
like oh we're going to use them for RL
environments. I think mostly a scam.
I really don't care about stuff like
disrupting global economy or whatever.
Like the world is very simple in my like
the way I look at it. It's like there
are a lot of problems that exist. Um
they're obviously more important than a
lot of the other things that we spend
most of our days thinking about. Like
disease is not solved. Resources are
scarce.
They don't have to be.
Like we have a lot of problems that
we're are we are going to solve in the
next hundred years that we're going to
look back on like, wow, those cavemen
could have solved that so much earlier
and they didn't.
Just [ __ ] solve them now.
I don't know.
things very simple to me.
How would I scale up approach work in
terms of application? The stuff I'm
doing now
probably just bigger lab, you know,
trying out just kind of trying out this
stuff in various areas to get a better
sense of like where things need to be
better for it to work
I don't know. Prime is sort of like
whatever. They do some stuff, I guess.
programming originally like games, but I
was 11 or something, so I don't know
what you'd expect,
Well, it's just like I'm not even using
this to implement stuff. You have to
realize this is just like straight
refactoring stuff and it's still [ __ ]
up like really easy things.
Totally stupid, right?
Why? Like
there's no reason to ever do
Are you sshing in a tin? So, I was and
then uh both of our tiny boxes just
dropped a GPU randomly and we can't run
anything on them. So, so far that's
probably cost me in the realm of eight
or $9,000
and it's probably going to cost me 15
grand by the time I actually get back in
person to be able to repair them. More
if any of the cards are actually dead.
So, uh yeah, kind of a disaster overall.
We kind of just negotiate a price for
the thing that we're doing. It's not
like replaceable work or anything. It's
highly skilled.
It's like cutting edge research.
How much kernel dev and learning can be
done with a 5090? That's what I'm
running on.
That's all you need. Like a 5090 is
actually the fastest chip for this.
You don't need a Pro 6000 at all.
We're not. Look at this. One gig of
VRAM. Most of our stuff uses like two to
six gigs of VRAM. You don't need any of
the black wells.
Yeah, but I mean at the same time Cuda
is very good.
What are we doing today?
We are pretty much doing pre-release
work.
We're cleaning up various leftover bits
of the codebase. Uh we've gotten some
major PF improvements right at the end
here. We have new soda on a lot of
stuff. And um I am going to be
doing lots of end integrations and fixes
as well in a second here.
be able to fix this. I got one thing to
figure out on the side here
quick.
Sorry.
I mean, it's just like what the [ __ ]
right?
you start learning.
Yeah, my guides.
I have lots of articles, research
articles, but also educational ones.
tall free.
I'm so confused. And let me finish let
me finish what I'm doing on this side
here. And then I will uh I'll just
figure out like why this thing is being
so dumb.
I don't know if I'd recommend C++ like
at all.
I generally think people do Python and
then do C. It's in my guide actually.
You spend a little bit of time if you're
brand new to programming in Python and
then you go to C
and that's it.
And then stuff is like generally good
and it makes sense and it isn't
horrendous.
I mean
I very very rarely see good C++ code
like
It's like, hey, should I just learn?
It's like I do you really want to spend
your life just working with [ __ ]
terrible code bases? Cuz like honestly,
it's one of the most frustrating things
ever is software engineering with like
stupid code bases. It's like if your job
is professionally to solve puzzles, but
to solve puzzles with like idiots that
have half the pieces stuck up their
noses or whatever. It's just awful.
you know,
you want to subject yourself to that,
like, I guess, sure, go ahead. I can't
stop you. But um you should know what
you're getting into.
Zigg is generally like okay.
I don't really have a need for it, but
it seems fine.
It's just that C in general, it's like C
gives you fewer things to [ __ ] make a
mess with.
Like a lot of CC code is just kind of
easy and obvious.
It's a very small language.
Um,
it's kind of more obvious when you're
being an idiot about things.
Let me finish. Just one thing to do on
this side here and then I will uh I'll
continue on the code. I don't know
what's going on here. We'll fix this.
How many people are watching this?
plus whatever's on X. 17 on YouTube,
eight on Twitch, and then however many
on X. It doesn't tell us.
Cool. Um, yeah, it is going to be cool
though today. Like we do have some fun
plans because as soon as I finish this,
I'm hoping this is like going to be
9600ish lines, maybe 9,500ish lines by
the time I'm done cleaning. And I'm not
going to do all of the cleaning today
cuz that would just be incredibly boring
in one session. I'm going to get it to
be like decent, which is just fixing
these last few changes. We will uh we'll
merge it and then we'll uh we'll have
some fun time on all the different
environments that I get to mess with,
right?
Yeah, but X doesn't tell you concurrent
viewers. X only tells you X tells you
the total number of people that have
like scrolled past your post or
whatever.
I can't do anything about the ads. I
literally have it set on the minimum.
Does cleaning help?
Cleaning up the code. Absolutely.
Learning C.
The Cbook
though, honestly, the Cbook just tells
you the language specifics. Like, you
kind of just need to know the basics of
the language and then implement some
things. Implement some basic RLNs.
It's how I mostly I mean I learned C in
uh in college but I never used it.
That's how I got back into it.
It's like a very simple language.
There's not much to learn. You're mostly
just learning how a computer works if
you don't know that already.
Uh X's view count doesn't really show
concurrent.
Load become faster or small both. It's
important that the code is compact. It's
incredibly important that the code is
compact. Um, a lot of the speed
optimizations come from just making the
logic very tight and then noticing
redundancy.
Stanford good for CS.
Uh
I don't know compared to what frankly
my systems classes were so terrible that
like I didn't touch C for the next
decade. They were [ __ ] horrid. Um my
intro theory course was very nice.
My intro programming course was okay.
Not great, but like okay. Intro data
structures was okay. Uh
what else was good? CS 231N the uh the
deep learning class was very very good.
One of the few courses I actually will
say pretty much exclusively good things
about.
Oh, yes. I guess if they call it that,
sure.
Let me use a restroom real quick and
grab a drink and then we will figure out
what the hell is wrong with this. I I
don't know what's happening with this.
It's very weird. Um, and then we will
we'll fix some stuff from there because
it's just being dumb.
what we're going to do now. Um,
it does not
the encoder writes logets.
So then we just have to figure out this
advantage versus loss thing.
Did you take RL course? No, there wasn't
any RL back when I was there.
horses at least.
Hello,
welcome.
I am sort of
let me think about this. So grid size
the issue here is going to be
the PO loss.
is going to have a different launch
architecture, right?
Because that's going to be purely
elementwise.
Whereas the uh advantage function is
going to be sequence-wise.
J needs packed
live V
before the loss
on one line gather of the last column.
J does not read
importance.
Okay. Yeah, that's just this is very
janky.
There's got to be a way to do this that
makes some sense, right?
Okay.
So, this thing needs importance.
It's a lot of just moving the order of
things around, frankly.
Like, do you see how with this thing, I
told it to do something and it got stuck
because it couldn't make literally the
one leap of logic that's like, oh, this
piece of logic is down here, but in
fact, we could move it up here and then
we wouldn't have this dependency.
This is why I say these things are not
smart. they fail conse like they
consistently will fail at like one-step
reasoning problems
uh in complex domains.
It's like okay the domain knowledge a
bit is a bit complex but once you have
the domain knowledge it's a very very
simple problem
to reason out.
Yeah, to be fair, a lot of research
scientists are absolutely terrible
programmers.
Presumably they they have engineers, but
uh and good ones.
That would actually be funny though,
wouldn't it? That like the simplest
explanation of why uh like the all the
AI writes such bad code is because the
devs think that it's writing good code.
This is a little annoying. I didn't
expect to have to do this now, but it is
kind of genuinely the case that um
needed at this point. So,
it'd be pretty funny if if Nvidia didn't
know either, don't you think?
like I don't know you. He's doing
something probably.
Here's the pitch.
We're going to give you equity. We're
not going to tell you when what it is.
You will give us compute.
We're going to assess this primary thing
just by whether it's shorter. If it's
shorter, we'll merge it. Shorter and
faster, we'll merge it and we'll
consider from there.
To be fair, Ilia was actually like very
very smart.
Well, I mean, like was in the sense of
when I uh was at Open AI and talked to
him. I haven't spoken to the guy since.
Ilia was very focused. Very very focused
guy.
That regressed. Actually, that is a
regression right there.
How can you even value a startup? Well,
you just pick a number.
How do you think they do it? They just
pick a number. They're like, "Ah, yes. I
think it's this one is worth $20
trillion.
This one, n this one's not very
valuable. This one's only worth $500
billion.
Mhm. I'm just letting it basically
numerical check versus the previous
because it's making a mess here. Um,
finally eval is very simple. It's just
whether we make it shorter, which we
should because basically I noticed that
it was redoing the logic calcs.
I could just undo all of this stuff and
just drop vrace entirely,
but um I think that practically
speaking, you know, importance would be
a kind of a nice thing to log anyways.
So,
I think it's free.
I don't think the structure gets any
more complex either.
Automate research.
Uh, let me know when anybody else has RL
working that they got within the
language model.
It's going to be like the language model
get cloned puffer lib and now RL works.
Oh my god.
This is the same speed as before.
914 might be a little bit slower. We'll
double check.
It's pretty funny. It's like we used to
have a lab with a thousand people doing
research, but now we have a lab with
2,000 people trying to automate the
research. Has any research gotten done?
Well, no, not really.
But if we automate it, it'll be really
cool.
Yeah, they're really great. That's why
I've been fighting with them to do some
basic refactors for the last three
hours.
Can I move this code down to here? Oh,
no. You can't move that code down to
there. That wouldn't work at all. Why
can't I do that? Well, because there's
this piece of code over here. What if I
move this piece of code up to there? Oh,
yeah. Then that would work really well.
Oh, okay.
It's kind of funny that every like every
year it seems like the research space
just gets fundamentally less and less
serious.
Like I will freely admit that by the
time uh I got into ML, ML was already
pretty easy.
Like if you got into ML before deep
learning era, that [ __ ] was hard.
And it also didn't particularly work
very well to be fair, which was like
How was OpenAI internship? Awesome.
I have uh I've been pretty public in
saying it was the best place I've ever
worked.
I don't think it's the same company
remotely today, mind you.
Perfect.
See, that wasn't so hard, was it?
Lovely.
Perfect.
How much you get paid for a PhD?
Uh, nothing. Like as a student, you
mean?
I don't know. Was it like
40k, 50k. Okay.
20k 30k.
Yeah, you can't live on 30k though. So,
uh it's been adjusted so that you can
actually like
hover rent and [ __ ]
What if I don't have a guy? So, I mean,
I just I knew my adviser going in
because I worked with him at OpenAI.
So,
I didn't have that problem.
Hang on. Let me fix this thing on my
other side.
Yeah, UK kind of just screws everyone
though.
purchasing power parody.
See, the thing is that's [ __ ]
Um
because
like the reason that's [ __ ] is
because if you wanted to in the US if
you're making like five times the amount
and saying oh but it's five times
cheaper which is not you can just like
move to the UK
with all your money or anywhere else in
the world that you want.
So like the oh it's quite good for local
is always [ __ ]
The only thing that I think is
legitimate with that is like the like
the minimum amount that you have to
spend
um
like in wherever it is you're working.
That can be adjusted, but all the other
adjustments are kind of [ __ ]
Basically, people come up with a lot of
really, really, really good reasons why
they shouldn't actually be paying you
anything.
Yep.
Staged. Okay.
We have a bunch of [ __ ] in here.
Are you currently working or what's the
game plan?
Um, I have this on the side. I'm doing
the uh the merge. We're merging this
clean. And then we're going to start on
the environments,
but this has plus 200 lines.
MIT might not pay that much. Well, it
also depends on um it depends on
fellowships and stuff.
I don't it's not 50 with um without like
extra fellowships and stuff. I think it
was
I think it was in the 40s.
I don't really remember.
What's dayto-day like during PhD?
You do some research and then probably
obsess over some annoying conference
deadlines and other [ __ ]
It's mostly like what I'm doing now, but
with more [ __ ]
The conference BS is so insane. Oh yeah,
it's even worse. It's not It's worse
now. It was bad when I was a PhD student
already, though. It's not like this is
just something in the last few years.
It's kind of always been [ __ ] but
it's way more [ __ ] because at least
people would be reading your stuff. I
mean, they'd be stupid, but they would
read it or part of it.
Huh?
Branches.
Branch protection rules. That's not what
I want.
General
default branch
No,
I want to remove. You used to be able to
go here, delete like a current branch,
and then just make a new one under the
same name.
They [ __ ] with it.
Goody devs.
I genuinely don't like doing like branch
deletions from uh command line just
because
I just am always afraid something's
going to be [ __ ] up with their API and
I figure that they'll test their browser
more.
Yeah. How?
Why couldn't I get to this
next to the drop down?
No. Oh, here. Okay.
They definitely still moved it.
Okay. So, we get rid of this. H. Undo
that. Definitely undo that. That would
be very bad. That's why I do this from
the browser.
That right there is your perfect
example.
I'd have it locally anyways, but still.
Okay. So, this one goes away
and then
that closed some PRs.
It shouldn't.
cool. So, we have this now. Eight files
again. We're back to what it's supposed
to be.
was closed in Pathfinder.
Um, okay. I'm going to need a list of
those. I didn't even know that GitHub
did that. That's annoying.
Uh, well, actually, that's perfect. The
tracker just gives me a list. I'll go
address those because I'm going to still
get Pathfinder and stuff.
I don't need the PR open to be able to
merge it. I just need to not forget
them.
You can resend it as if you want.
Otherwise, I'll just grab it.
Okay. So, I guess then the next thing is
the binary.
that's fine. Then you can't then the
error is impossible.
which is the one.
I literally have it set to 30 seconds of
ads, which is the lowest it will let me
set it to.
If you have Prime, you can drop a Prime
sub. It'll disable the ads, I'm pretty
sure. But that's about it
if you don't have um like Twitch Turbo
or whatever it is.
And again, this is not like me being
able to set it. That's just how Twitch
works.
It lets me set ads, but minimum 30
seconds.
Reream doesn't even show me subs. That's
a little awkward.
Is there anything that we need from
here?
Why does moving a directory take? What
is it doing?
That should be a no. Like that should
literally just be a rename.
What the [ __ ] man?
Okay.
done.
Fine.
Okay, perfect. Yeah, this is exactly set
up the way it needs to be. And then a
lot of this is going to be pretty easy
from here. Um, it's going to take me a
second to figure out how to set this up,
but it'll be well well worth it.
Turns out we got uh this was running the
whole time.
I see like 18ks.
That's very good.
Just going to automate a bunch of like
testing basically and then I'm going to
hopefully be able to just spend my time
debugging all the ones that don't work.
Do all M's need a sweep? Yeah, they
will.
Did you solve async algo? We solved
quite a bit of stuff. I'll show it off
in a second here. Let this job get
running. Um,
cool. So, here's the uh here's the
situation at the moment, right?
We now have a pretty compact
I still need to prune a couple things,
but overall pretty compact
source.
Ah [ __ ] What do we have on this box
that matters?
Hang on. Let me let me figure something
out real quick. So I messed this up.
Okay. This is fine though. I can just
get rid of the checkpoints.
It's fine.
Just take this.
What the [ __ ] is wrong with this stupid
thing?
I I remember this being a thing. I'm
trying to remember what I did to fix
this.
rewind stream, but only if you're a sub.
That's weird. That's Twitch, as far as
I'm aware. You can let me know if
there's a way to uh change the setting
for that. I don't think there is,
though.
Yeah. So, what I'm going to do here is
I'm basically just going to set this
thing up to test all of the ends.
I'm a [ __ ] That's why.
Yep, there we go. Stupid. I just forgot
that I made a change. Okay, that's my
that's my bad.
I'm going to be right back. Let me use a
restroom real quick.
Previous comment test.
Finn, I think Finn did have conditional
trees. We're going to actually merge Net
Hack in in a bit here. We're just going
to try to get the initial web pages
working first.
This is basically just automating a big
chunk of the really annoying, boring
release work that I normally have to do,
which is just testing all the M's,
making sure that um stuff runs.
and use puffer next research project.
Welcome. You're going to have Puffer 5
available to you quite soon.
This is it right here.
Pretty compact.
YouTube is is blocking GA. That's so
funny.
Um Oh, yeah. I can say what I h what
happened with GE. So, you don't need
Vrace. We left the Vrace path in because
you can still play with it in case
anybody doubts that result. And also
because I did have a very nice
theoretical result with that. Anyways,
um
you don't need prioritize replay because
of the muon uh not muan the new
architecture having a very long horizon
bootstrap. So we stripped out prioritize
replay. We still have soda. You don't
need advantage normalization. That one
you don't need because of muon which is
super nice. We were able to simplify
things quite a bit. Uh this is going to
be like 9.5kish lines. There is a little
bit of bloat right now in the CPU in
front and stuff that we can remove.
I think 9.5ishk will be the rough target
for uh
for 5.0.
Vrace is going to be yes vrace will be
off by default
and it will not be in the sweeps. So we
delete four or five hypers I believe
from the defaults which is very Nice.
new architecture. New architecture is uh
from 40. It's Muan. Muan um Puffernet.
It's um Mingru, not Muan. Excuse me. Mr.
with highway connections.
This thing is so what this thing is
doing now for reference.
You can see all these runs
with all different VRAM usage.
This is Snake, Tetris, Asteroids, Drone.
You see, it's just running lots of
different ends. But basically, I'm just
automating
um testing all the train runs and I'm
going to have it build all of them to
the website. And I'm also going to have
it dump a web page with all of the
current scores so I can see which ends
are obviously either broken and that
they won't run or broken and that the
current config sucks.
What am I doing? Looks interesting. This
is pre-release uh cleanup and testing
for Puffer Lib 5.0, which is the next
major release of the fastest
reinforcement learning library out
there. We train tiny superhuman agents
on very small amounts of hardware. Um,
we can push through like ridiculous
amounts of training data. We have all
sorts of research that's co-adapted for
this exact use case. And I stream most
of the research.
At the moment, we've I spent this
morning like cleaning up a bunch of
just refactor mess,
like pruning out some code that we no
longer needed and refactoring some stuff
around it. That went pretty well. We got
some performance increases as well out
of that. And now I am at the part where
I can basically just automate a lot of
the pre-release work where I have to
make sure I have all of the different
environments running.
the first stage of that I can mostly
automate. So that's what's going on here
small how small one GPU I'm using a
single 5090 for testing but um even so
like this local machine has a 3080 and I
can train pretty much anything on that
as well. It'll just take two to 4x
longer.
Our big runs are like uh 8x5090.
That is considered big. But I mean if
you look at the amount of data that we
can push through it, it is actually big
because at that size we can do over a
100 million steps per second training
for a lot of our runs.
what kind of parameters?
Um, anywhere from like tens of thousands
to low tens of millions.
And you'd be surprised how much you can
do with that. Like you can get
superhuman on a ton of tasks with that.
I think the driving model is like a
million parameters, maybe less. Drone
models definitely under a million.
Some of our harder problems end up being
like 12 million or whatever,
but most of our professional
applications end up being like single
digit millions.
Uh my articles on X X.com/juarez.
I have lots of educational material.
It's all free.
Buffer itself is open source.
Yeah, this is all throw away.
This is fine.
this. Yeah. Okay. This is still queuing
more M's. Cool.
Nice.
I build something using model. Cool.
You can train all of our models locally.
They're all pretty quick. In fact, look,
this is like all of our different ends
being trained one GPU each.
We have like 50 of them.
So, I'm mostly just trying to figure out
which ones need um manual
work or manual repairs and which of them
are like already working
and which of them like I can
semi-automate the stuff versus which of
them are really just going to need me to
spend a few Of course.
Okay,
this looks almost done.
This should give us uptime, score, and
PF.
Oh, look at this.
This is cool.
We might even want to keep something
like this depending on how much of a
mess it is.
probably not keep a live version of it
obviously, but we can keep like a just a
static table on the uh the site.
so we have lots and lots of ants.
Yep.
major release points of 5.0 No pure end
to end Q to C, no Python whatsoever.
Um, async mode training delivers about
2x PF. We have GPU M support. We have
additional CUDA graphing and kernel
improvements that give about another 50%
for small models.
So, mostly a lot of PF. We also do have
a very small soda just from a couple
very small algorithm tweaks.
That actually makes the core algorithm
quite a bit simpler as well and easier
to sweep.
Oh yeah, we still have to do that in
constellation. I forgot about that.
Okay, this is not bad. We can uh we can
work with this. Oh,
We're going to keep it really simple
today.
I could just like try to summarize
everything all at once, but we're going
to just keep the work really really
simple today. We're going to have more
complicated stuff to do tomorrow when we
hit the uh like the heavy ends is my
guess. So, we're just going to keep the
work really simple today. And the goal
will just be to have this page like
mostly full of good demos. us.
0 point. Oh, thank you. Glitzy, can you
uh can you pull that up real quick?
Actually, if you have that run, can you
tell me whether the model looks decent?
Like is the PF miscalibrated on that?
Edge AI. Edi doesn't mean anything.
That's a meaningless term
unless you're talking about working in
AI porn in which sure that has plenty of
application and money.
I don't know. I like to give I like to
give stupid questions stupid answers.
I only give willfully stupid questions
mean answers. Normally I just give
stupid answers.
Glitzy isn't his name. Yeah, I I don't
know about that one. There's uh
I mean my screen my screen name in games
is typically hex so I don't think I'm
one to talk
that's edgy in a whole different way
the hot dog I don't even know what is
said I don't know what this conversation
I would take the config for that real
quick.
This is kind of fun. This is the exact
way I wanted this to work where I just
like basically have all the ends. I
vaguely remember like the stata the
status of each environment so I know
roughly what needs to be done in each
case and it's like typically a
relatively simple set of experiments or
tests or whatever. This should catch
like almost all of the M's worth of
screwiness
just today without me having to do
without me having to do too much for it
which is great because I always hate
doing the pre-release work. It's just
always such a pain. And uh if I have to
do less of it, yay. You know, we get
back on to real research faster.
Maybe I'll have an extra couple weeks to
sneak something else into uh 40 or I
mean 50. Maybe I'll have an extra couple
weeks to do net hack and sol. No,
anything other than just wasting the
time dealing with random [ __ ]
Yeah, you can let me know uh when you
see the asteroids policy if it looks
like perfect or if it looks like kind of
jank
boarding. Mocha.
Wait, what? Mocha?
Mocha's a boss in Runescape. All right.
If you reporting Mocha, like that Mocha,
I'd be very excited.
That thing is hard.
Oh, okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That one.
Well,
that is also exciting.
I may look into that. No, no, no, no.
Leave the Runescape stuff to Valo, okay?
Like you need to be a top 1% player in
the game to understand whether shit's
working correctly.
Believe all to do it.
We definitely need to showcase some of
Alo's work with 5. It's really good.
We'll give him a little bit of spotlight
as well on uh
there are a few different projects I
definitely want to make sure we
highlight a fair bit with uh with 5.
Definitely one of them.
What time is it?
>> Jesus. How is it 400 p.m.? I thought it
was like 1 or two. Huh?
Well, no worries.
I know I'm going to be doing a evening
stream tonight anyways.
I do want to make sure I have my headset
charged for dinner.
To be fair, I did get stuck refactoring.
Um,
I did get stuck refactoring for a while
and we got 60 MPS today, so I can't be I
can't complain. We got stuff done. And I
I really don't have anything to do
tonight other than just work on this.
So, I'm probably gonna just go get a a
quick dinner in an hour
and uh just like come back and stream
this until I go to bed.
bunch of checkpoints to go through.
Uh, so from what I see, let's see, it
looks like it found a utterly massive
network. And I looked at the OBS real
quick just now, and it looks like it
needs an entity encoder.
because it's just like a list of all the
positions,
but this is exactly why I'm doing it
this way. Like we have 50 M's to go
through. You know, maybe half of them
will work out of the box. The other half
of them I expect most of them to sort of
just fall over if I give Brock like
roughly, you know, it's probably this.
Go see if this is the thing that's
wrong. And then there'll be a few M's le
left that are still weirdly broken that
I'll actually have to deal with myself,
You want order. It is order invariance.
J. It's when you have a set of points or
a set of things in the obs.
So you have a set of asteroids you can
observe. The alternative to this would
be to uh to like line them out on a
grid.
Why do you vibe code?
I'm not vibe coding.
This is debugging. Let me explain to you
what I'm doing actually. Um, here I'll
show you what I'm doing in a second.
This thing is not actually supposed to
be writing any code for the most part.
Like there might be a few bug fixes out
of this. Um, but this is not actually
writing like any durable code. So look,
this is a throwaway interface. Okay,
this is for debugging. It's not getting
kept, at least not in this form. If I
like having something like this, I will
write a version of this myself that is
much less bloated and um like contains
key information. Okay, so what I have
this thing do, so first of all, I
finished a refactor before. All right,
and now we have a stable version of
Puffer 5.
This leaves us with like 50 environments
to test. Normally I have to go through
every single release and I have to go
through each and every environment. I
have to build it myself. I have to run
training and like half of them will work
out of the box and half of them will not
work out of the box. Like I will have
broken something in them in the process
of uh you know doing the next version of
development. Right? So what I did is I
spun up an HGPU vast instance. Speaking
of which, let me make sure that I'm not
running out of credits on the thing.
Uh, $800.
Think we're okay.
Yeah, I think we're okay. Um,
so I spun up an HGPU vast box.
I gave this thing access to the VAS box
as well as access to a local build of
our docs and uh the build command and
the run command for everything. And I
basically said, "Hey, go run all of our
default experiments,
right?" and list everything on like a
throwaway web page here locally for me
and then for all the ends that don't
train correctly, right? And you can't
like deploy the build to the website
basically where anything goes wrong like
ask me what to do because I have in my
head I roughly know what tends to happen
with each of all these environments but
having to go through everything manually
just takes absolutely forever and is
miserable every single release. So, I
figured this time I would give this a
shot. And this is not going to work for
every env. But if this works for 80% of
the Ms, that still saves me a lot of
time.
Let's see. Do you have your uh the
boxabon config as well
from your sweep?
How cool. Never seen a stream like this.
Do you even check code anymore? I check
a lot of code. In fact, I read like
literally I just spent weeks on the
refactor like cutting four to 5,000
lines off of the source code of Puffer
like bit by agonizing bit.
I generally consider the models to be
very very bad at writing good code. But
that that does not mean they're not
useful for some stuff, right? I can
still automate a lot of stuff, but like
all the core code essentially still
requires a huge amount of manual effort
and will for the foreseeable future
setup runs for different models. Uh this
is a different type of RL. So if you
check puffer.ai, these are all
environments with models that will run
on the game or on like the drone or the
driving and all in your browser. So we
train tiny task specific models on
ridiculously fast simulation. We're
talking tens of millions of steps per
second.
And then we use these to test our core
RL algorithm and the core capabilities
of our library.
This is the highest performance RL
library out there by over an order of
magnitude.
Um
and this is how we benchmark everything.
asteroid six layers. Yeah, I saw that.
Yeah, I already have um I basically I'm
just going to try the minimal uh entity
encoder on that. Let's see. I think
that'll probably do a decent job. We'll
see.
No, people are legitimately asking
asking me that, dude.
And that's just basically um I don't
actually blame the viewers for that
except the people that are like, should
we think at all? I mostly blame um I
blame the big labs for deceptive
marketing.
It's basically people that are now like
raising hundreds of billions of dollars
to completely pervert the field and lie
their asses off. I kind of look at the
um the AI lab execs like I look at the
uh you know the Marblero execs, all the
cigarette advertising agencies and [ __ ]
back in the
highest boxabon
also a chunker. Uh boxabon is allowed to
be a chunker. That one's legitimately
hard.
See all these sweeps that you did
actually help me. Thank you.
I assume people are smart enough. Dude,
you can't like they're spending billions
and billions of dollars to like convince
people of this [ __ ]
Like
it's like were people dumb for smoking
cigarettes when doctors were smoking
cigarettes?
No, they just lied their asses off a
bunch.
There are a lot of ways that things can
shake out, Jess.
Um,
the cool thing is that a lot of tech
does asymmetrically favor individuals.
So
like my small model RL for instance, you
basically can't lock this behind closed
doors in a lab because people can just
run it on their laptops.
Um, eventually we will get to a point
where the models get really small and
are still very capable and they kind of
just like can't do anything about it.
One can write good code snippets. Um,
not really.
You can write working code snippets. You
can even write fast code snippets a lot
of the time, but they're still bad.
No, it's not as it's not the crypto and
NFTs. I don't think that's fair. The
crypto and NFT people that was just
dumb. Like that was just people being
[ __ ] stupid. Um this is much much
much better of a scam.
it's the fact that they're even like
like misleading the public as a whole.
It's kind of like um a side effect of
them mostly misleading investors and
[ __ ]
and regulators
cuz they mostly just care that
businesses are using
as many credits as possible.
All of like the fear-mongering over like
oh will AI just do all the jobs and
[ __ ] That's kind of just like side
effect.
There's a difference between being
misled and being willfully stupid. Jess,
we still flame the people who like being
willfully stupid.
I don't know. When people ask me like,
"Hey, why should I bother trying to
learn anything if the language model is
just going to be better than me?" I just
be like, "Well, you probably shouldn't.
Drop out of college, go to trade school,
you'll be happier."
But, um,
that's kind of just the extreme case.
I the correct level of abstraction for
code is code. It's not English.
You can sometimes shortcut certain
things
where like you can basically describe
what you want precisely enough given the
existing codebase. There's only one way
of doing the thing. But in general, the
precise the correct level of subtraction
is code.
Where can I learn more about the RL and
the stuff I work on? Um, x.com/juarez.
If you just click my articles tab on
there,
I have lots of uh educational material,
but I also have like research articles
on all of our latest breakthroughs.
Who did this end come from anyways?
Jack B
The brightest it gets. Really? That's
weird. My camera's usually fine in the
uh in this
I only knew about neural MMO. What is
Puffer? Puffer is what I've been
building for the last 3 years. It is the
fastest
general purpose uh reinforcement
learning library.
We use it for
games, control,
various industrial sims.
And I'm currently working on the 50
release, which brings training up to 60
million steps per second on the high end
on a single GPU.
couple algorithm simplifications and
improvements, whole bunch of new
environments, new state-of-the-art
results and so on.
Yeah, I'm still using my keyboard. Wait
until you hear that. I'm still using my
brain, too.
That's a real shocker in this day and
age,
though. This does not particularly count
as it. Well, I don't know. This was kind
of a little bit of a clever setup cuz
this is just a whole bunch of sort of
dumb manual work.
This was kind of a clever setup, I'd
say.
just a little
making a library optimized.
Um well in our case to give you an idea
there's a huge amount of CUDA
optimization and simplification.
We have a custom architecture that only
really makes sense because of all of the
high perf stuff we done. like we have a
literal custom model architecture that
is better than your normal LSTM and much
much faster. Uh we have our own hyperp
sweep tools and algorithm which again
only makes sense because of how fast
everything is. We have our own
visualization tools to handle the
massive massive amounts of data that we
produce from all of this because we got
sick of like wannabe being a laggy piece
of crap. Uh what else?
Algorithm improvements. We do algorithm
side research. We build more and more
environments in Sims for testing as our
algorithms get better.
That's more what building puffer entails
than building like any old library
entails.
So we can get 18k in 2 hours.
17.8 8 and 85 minutes.
I am basically just streaming this all
weekend though. Uh the dev at the moment
is pretty chill because I'm just having
to test all the environments. It's more
pre-release work than it is just core
dev right at this point.
Um
I did some refactoring early today
though for several hours. So I guess
that counts, right?
Oh, we have 40 people watching between
Twitch and YouTube. Hello everyone.
Aren't all the RL people supposed to be
at RLC this weekend?
But yeah, I'll be here all weekend
pretty much. Anybody wants to hang out
and chat RL stuff or whatever.
Envod
is 94%.
Well, we kind of expected that. Jess,
what's the SPS?
Okay, that was an easy fix.
That was an easy fix.
I changed the reward function to the
reward function that I suggested Yasine
um when he was doing like the
multi-pendulum crap.
I don't think anybody did. I just have
the double one. We might just make it
end pendulum.
RL optimization? No, I mean I kind of do
a lot of different things within RL.
Puffer is more of like my comprehensive
effort to make RL sane, stable, broadly
useful.
So it just turns out that a lot of what
was holding RL back was not the
algorithms, it was the uh the pure
infrastructure and speed. Um so a lot of
it goes into that and there is still
some work that goes into the algorithm
because that's not unimportant,
right?
Same with the architecture.
Our new architecture is pretty good.
Constellation
visualization toolkit. I made this.
This is super nice because now I can
just Okay.
Actually, the um the area that I am most
interested in seeing puffer applied
longer term is in low-level molecular
simulation
or biology and material science. But I
think biology first and foremost. I
don't know enough about that area yet.
Frankly, I'm still kind of just focused
on the core of RL because a lot of the
time the failure cases in RL are very
unintuitive.
And I really want it to be super stable
and consistent before we try it in an
area that is dramatically harder to
interpret results. But I think that that
will happen within the next year or so.
Um, Puffer's been getting much much
better at a very rapid pace. It's almost
there. Couple last things that are still
weird. Any blogs? Yeah, we have blogs.
Let's follow X right here. This article
here. High throughput recurrent network
for Puffer Lib 4.0.
There you go.
Visualizing 20,000 experiments with
constellation.
Engineering behind 20 million step per
second RL training.
Lots of posts. So, there's educational
stuff there, but then there's also like
just our latest research.
What makes you want to focus on biology?
Um, curing disease
in general,
it's the important problem for all of us
at some point fundamentally.
So, um, things that we fixed, by the
way, already. Heart pole blaster, double
pendulum,
asteroids should be solved. I'm guessing
2488 will be good. Box bun, that's
reproing.
All the other ones that solved out of
the box are on here.
didn't see. I actually I wonder if it
updated double pendulum.
Did it update this?
It didn't update the Perf yet. I'll have
it do that.
What are what am I working on now? I'm
basically just working on going through
all of the M. Um, look, we have all of
these different M's in Pupper. See, it's
a huge number of different environments.
You can actually see them all here. So
these are all different games,
simulations,
test tasks, you know, and
I have a vast box
uh with eight GPUs,
and I'm essentially just having Rock go
through and run experiments and say,
"Hey, you know, this one is not working.
This one's not getting the score that we
got from last version. You know, this
one is getting the score, but it's
taking too long." like all the different
problems and I'm kind of just like using
it to orchestrate very very basic
experiments because I in my head I
roughly know for all of these
environments I know the state of the
code of them and I know roughly like how
stable they are what needs to be done
when like some of them are slightly
unfinished so I'm basically just
orchestrating a bunch of relatively
simple test work at the moment I have to
do this every version. Usually I do it
manually and it takes forever. So I just
basically spend 3 weeks being miserable
right before launch. So instead of that,
we're trying it this way. I'm still
going to have to do some of it manually,
but I'm hoping I only need to do it for
like three or five M's instead of 50.
How's life in MIT? Best college for
science
related careers?
I think for graduate school, yes.
Um,
I mean, how was MIT? It's very different
being there for grad school because
you're kind of just there doing research
in a lab. Um,
I worked with a few smart people there.
My work was still pretty individual.
I would say my adviser was good. I
didn't have to deal with a lot of the
[ __ ] that um you have to deal with
that worse universities. That's
generally the main perk at least if you
are um you know already you have your
own research agenda and you know roughly
what you need to be doing.
Oh the harness thing. This is literally
just like Grock build like the default
thing. Um, I really don't care much
about this language model, that language
model.
The thing that's nice with Grock is it's
just fast. That's the main reason.
Fay, that was when I was way younger.
Um, I did a little bit of research with
Justin in undergrad and but mostly when
I was still in high school. It was very
cool. I mean that's when they were still
working on the
uh the various uh classification
competitions. Olga was there, Carpathy
was there. Um Justin was doing visual
genome. I did some very janky ML work
for that that I'm sure was not super
useful as well as some data labeling
that I'm sure was super useful but you
know kind of whatever.
Uh,
I don't know. I ran some comn nets. I
trained some classifiers. They weren't
very good. I learned some basic
research, though, and I got a sort of a
head start on how do you do research
101.
I understood actually a fair amount of
the technicals all the way back then. I
just like didn't have any research
common sense whatsoever. That just takes
a few years to develop
any lessons from those legends.
I think that the coolest thing that I
would say came out of like the coolest
thing that you can publicly see from
that era is CS231N.
They made the best ML course by a mile
and they got a lot of the subtler points
right that all the other material at the
time and there wasn't very much of it
would get wrong. Um so much so it's
pretty much the only piece of
educational content I still recommend uh
heavily in ML overall.
I think that you can kind of see their
level of knowledge through that quite
well.
a lot of the early like fundamental
papers I think back then those were
pretty cool to see
in retrospect I can kind of see the way
that they did things but frankly like at
16 and brand new to research I probably
wasn't developed enough in uh in
research to fully appreciate a lot of
what they could do there
but I still like within A couple years
after that, I was already doing my own
stuff relatively decently. You know, I
did my own little bit of um language
modeling research. I set soda on uh one
of the research grade tasks at one
point. Um I published that. I had this
like really weird vision architecture
that was assembled per question
instance. That was kind of interesting.
And then pretty early on, I think by my
sophomore summer is when I already
started neural MMO. The rest is history.
What courses? 231N
still available publicly and uh my
guides recommend it quite heavily.
What time is it?
Almost 5. Time flies. Cheers.
The heck did I put this?
Where's my window?
Why doesn't localhost Google local host
by default? That's awful.
I think snake has let's see posted snake
at some point
right
How are my chat messages? It's not
pre-recorded.
What?
Pre-recorded screen.
Wait, do you think I'm like playing VODs
or something? I'm obviously responding
to things in the chat.
Yeah, this is just my OBS overlay. It's
going through reream, so there's a
little bit of chat delay and I'm also
doing a bunch of stuff at the same time,
so I'm missing some messages. Um,
but yeah, it's just like the typical
reream overlay. I'm live on X, YouTube,
and Twitch whenever I'm streaming my
dev. Though Reream does occasionally
mess up on one of those
this random live. No, no, no. If you
check the history, actually, there's
this fun graphic I have from my last
release. I'm sure I'm not going to
stream anywhere near this number of
hours for uh for this latest release,
but my article here, this was the
engineering article. The thumbnail is
just every single stream that I did. It
was like 900 hours of dev streams
in 6 months.
I haven't been super consistent lately
because it's the summer and uh I don't
know, Puffer 4 was a lot of work. So,
I'm still working hard, but not as
psychotically hard as I was for uh for
Puffer 4.
I'm still streaming a decent amount. Few
days a week at least.
Tried to ask what's the hard It's just
rock build. It's just like the standard
Grock thing. I really don't like I'm not
an LLM power user. Um like I really
don't care like oh what's the latest
model or whatever. I was using Rock 45
for the last like bunch of time before
six came out. Like the main thing I care
about is it's just fast because like the
models all get stuff wrong constantly
for me anyways.
like I don't think that they're that
good, but I'd rather at least have them
be fast and then I can correct stuff.
Particularly because when you'll see me
doing engineering tasks, uh you'll see
me using them for just like couple line
edits at a time for the most part. Not
so much for refactoring, but for any new
like new kernel code or whatever.
If you're real, I'm subbing. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. you have um
this is me on X. I post reinforcement
learning content. I stream all of my
dev. Uh puffer liib is free. It's open
source. You can get it at puffer.ai. If
you want to help me for free, you start
the repo. Um we have all of our
experiment data public here. Here are
all of the different environments. You
can literally watch neural nets play
them in your browser. This is an agent
running live in your browser. You can
train most of these models in seconds on
a laptop and it gets faster every
version. That's Puffer.
The current release is going to be I
worked very very hard at this. The new
release is going to be under 10k total
lines for everything.
That took a lot of work. It was like 15k
lines. Spent a lot of time trimming it.
It keeps forgetting as well to ask me
about the other ends.
burnt out more easily. Honestly, I just
find myself doing much shorter work days
a lot of the time. Um,
whenever I'm doing this type of stuff,
there's still large chunks of my work
where like the AI is not even
particularly useful and I prefer to do
stuff manually. Like if I'm ever writing
new environments, I still will end up
wanting to write pretty much all the
code manually. It's mostly for
refactoring and maintenance work that uh
you see me using more AI but like even
then on the core like I these things
produce awful awful awful code like it's
a huge number of manual iterations to
get to something that's decent right you
can't just say like oh make it better
make it shorter follow this what like it
the thing at a very fundamental level
does not understand how to write good
code like something as simple as hey you
know you have this duplicated here and
even though there's a dependency here if
you move this chunk of code here first
you don't need to duplicate it and you
break the dependency loop like basic
stuff like that um if you do it in a
context it's not super familiar with
like hyperf CUDA dev it makes really
really basic logical errors I don't know
how else to say it like it looks like oh
it's pretty good look it's doing stuff
in this CUDA space like this like
complex hyperf CUDA space But the thing
is, once you have the domain knowledge
to do stuff in that space, like the
logical errors it makes are errors that
you would not expect a 12-year-old to
make.
So, you just get this really alien
feeling thing where like everybody's out
there like, "Oh, look. It's amazing."
But actually, it's very, very, very
limited. It's still useful. Very useful,
but it's not AGI.
Definitely not AGI.
Okay, I'm waiting for it to give me back
some results.
this thing being dumb,
bro? It's got like three GPUs.
Yeah. Honestly, the most important thing
in my mind is just making the models
faster because like I don't expect them
to be able to just make the models
actually smart. Like that's just not
going to happen anytime soon. Um, if
they just made the models like 10x
faster though, that would be way way way
useful.
Actually, I saw OpenAI was doing that
with uh their custom hardware,
and that sounds pretty cool, but I'm
sure it's going to be ludicrously
expensive. So there.
not ideal.
Okay, we'll have to re sweep a little
bit.
I would be surprised if it's actually
decent.
Last I checked, the Gemini models have
just been really, really [ __ ] Like
unusably bad.
I also did not like the way that they
set everything up.
They may just made everything really
opaque and obnoxious.
no 2048's known to have a little bit of
score perf.
Snake is snake not on here.
Snake is not on here.
Yeah. Yeah. I think I pasted wrong.
We got 110. 10.
Oh yeah. Do we have um
sanities?
Oh, Pac-Man.
Cool. I can actually get some of these
to work.
Lots of these skip down. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Lots we can fix. Lots we can fix.
That doesn't work.
Okay.
Hopefully I'm mostly done. I really want
to do a microscope arm on Puffer. That'd
be cool.
That'd be cool.
We do need to figure out I honestly one
of the big things I need to do is I need
to take all the M's that have screwy PF
numbers and I need to find a way to
rescale them
so that one means the policy is Good.
I'm thinking we'd probably do
we make constellation like a top 20.
What do you think, guys?
Because there are a lot of M's that
really just don't need sweeps and like
we solve them. you know, it's solved.
Maybe we ship some fast hypers with it
or whatever. Maybe we do a little sweep,
but like it really doesn't need to have
a full burrito front for any purpose.
Am I working on pre-release stuff? We
got all these M's. They all need
testing.
All these different environments. Oops,
not these.
All these environments, lots of them
need testing.
And
I don't have the binaries working
locally, so I can't preview them.
But
I have a 8GPU box for running lots of
experiments.
And we're kind of just troubleshooting
some of the ones that aren't working
fully yet. Tetris here. This has been
running 10 minutes. Terraform's been
going.
Lime Volley is a little weird. Lots of
MS.
Rware's
hardware is good.
So yeah, ourware the regression was just
a um
a port error. This is what I figured.
Like half of the items that don't work
are just going to be minor port errors.
Uh so parrito front is is easy to
compute from the sweep. Let's see. It's
just more so like what ms are worth
bothering to report the results on.
Games developed. Some are developed by
me. Some of them are developed by the
community. They're not all games. We
have like the highest perf open source
self-driving sim and a good drone sim in
here as well. Let me use the restroom
real quick and we'll check on this for a
few uh another I don't know 15 20
minutes before
All right.
Stuck on the same problems this morning.
Well, I'm doing very easy work at the
moment to be fair.
This is like very easy stuff.
This morning I some of the um the
refactoring stuff this morning took a
fair bit of thought
and uh the
colonel like changes.
Hey, Jess
It's literally on YouTube. Like
it's Stanford CS231N.
Vast template for me
suffer with setup. I mean, uh, the vast
template is really, yes, actually, they
could, but it's really easy at this
point. You literally just grab a a CUDA
base image with like 256 gigs. All
right, you grab the install script and
you run install.sh. That's it.
Because you don't even need PyTorch
anymore or anything, right?
Like you don't need Python, you don't
need PyTorch, you don't need anything.
You just need the base CUDA depths and
you're good.
time he was fast. Yeah, 3 is way more
work, right? Cuz then you have the whole
CUDA stack, but also PyTorch. And now
PieTorch has the wrong CUDA that it
shipped with, but you need the CUDA that
it doesn't. Like, it's a mess.
Hoarding Mocha. We get
167 byte obs.
Okay, that's pretty good. And then we
expand it into 8 332
140k
1.9 mil SPS on eight.
I would suspect based on the model size
Jess that if that architecture is good
the kernels can be very very heavily
optimized.
Um that would be my expectation. So I
mean 1.9 mil SPS is fast enough to play
it a little bit and see if it does
something miraculous.
If it doesn't, then well, sucks. But
it was like 100k params, right?
There's no way you can't get 100k per
architecture into the millions of SPS.
I don't believe it.
It's not that many flops.
You might have to go to pretty big
batches to get it to be uh effective,
but should be doable.
Pick with defaults.
Well, I mean, pick something that you
can actually sweep, right, Jess? You
basically you adjust the time step range
for sweeps based on the hardware that
you actually have to allocate that you
can still get hundreds of experiments at
least.
And ideally, you want to start your
sweep with like a reasonably decent set
of hypers if you can.
I'm going to head to dinner in like 10
minutes. Um maybe a little less. So,
yeah, while I before I forget, for folks
that are watching, um, if you're new
around here, you like just watching
research done live, you're interested in
RL, whatever it may be, take a moment.
Puffer.ai, start the repo on GitHub.
It's free. It actually helps me out a
lot. Um, Discord is where you can get
involved with dev and all the other RL
content is on X.
Okay. Connect for finish. Tower climb is
still climbing
drone only hit.
Uh we landed a separate.
Okay,
looks good.
Seven six GPUs loaded at least. Power
climb.
any events
going to break it up
point something helpful. I'm going to go
check uh your robot uh your robotic arm
PR man. We're going to see based on that
render work with eval. Uh you have to do
puffer render or like dot slash render
whatever. Um just I have to fix that.
That's one of the things I've been
meaning to fix so that you will be able
to just have it render by default. Um
yeah, I got to go get some food. So,
thank you everyone. It is currently
5:42 p.m. I should be back in about an
hour. the seven and I think I'll
probably stream another two or three
hours tonight. Um, I have the full
weekend open to myself and other than
getting a little bit of exercise in over
it, I pretty much just want to grind
pre-release
and Monday as well. I have basically all
of Monday open until the late evening.
So, thanks everyone.